[Musique]
vous allez vous consacrer au festival du
film russe à paris qui est intitulé
quand les russes ne bouleverse nous
bouleverse toujours vous savez parce
qu'on les comprend pas il nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à renault alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes dit rien
c'est la même culture c'est la même
façon de penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin né
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
t'es pas tout de suite il faut passer au
delà de quelques quelques obstacles mais
je crois que l'avenir est à milan
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la france commencera à fermer des bases
dans le nord du mali ch d'ici à la fin
de l'année annoncé par emmanuel macron
il ya un mois la fin de l'opération dark
and so précise le président français
s'entretenait cet après midi avec les
chefs d'état du g20 qui sera elle qui
l'a assuré qu'à terme 2500 à 3000
militaires france
romain tenue dans la région est les
talibans disent contrôler 85% du
territoire afghan depuis le mois de mai
les insurgés se sont emparés de vastes
zones rurales se rapprochant de
plusieurs grandes villes
il affirme s'être emparé ce vendredi de
deux postes frontières majeur avec
l'iran et le turkménistan
une délégation talibane et des reçus
aujourd'hui à moscou
les détails dans ce journal el aziz
durement frappée par le variant delta
couvre feu à bangkok et dans neuf
provinces thaïlandaises
au vietnam les 9 millions d'habitants de
hô chi minh ville entame de semaine de
confinement interdiction notamment de se
rassembler et fermetures des écoles bars
et discothèques à séoul la capitale de
la corée du sud qui s'apprête à vivre à
partir de lundi c'est plus dur
restrictions depuis le début la pandelle
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france 1 semaine
consacrée à l'avenir de la lutte contre
le terrorisme au sahel
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu cet
après midi avec les chefs d'état
nigérian tchadien maliens burkinabè et
mauritanien
seul le président nigérien mohamed
bazoum était présent à paris ses
homologues en visioconférence emmanuel
macron a donc précisé ses intentions lui
qui annonçait le 10 juin dernier une
transformation profonde de la présence
militaire française au sahel
il a déclaré que la france commencera à
fermer des bases dans le nord du mali où
second semestre de cette année elle
maintiendra à terme entre 2500 à 3000
hommes dans la région contre 5100
aujourd'hui l'impératif d'endiguer une
diffusion de la menace au sud elle se
traduira par une réduction nos
empreintes militaires les plus au nord
ces fermetures s'étaleront sur le second
semestre de l'année 2021 et seront
achevés d'ici le début de l'année 2022
cette évolution de notre dispositif nous
la mettrons en oeuvre donc dans les
prochains mois elle est celle qui nous
paraît le mieux répondre évidemment à
l'évolution de la menace avec un corps
du président bazoum que je remercie ce
nouveau dispositif comme je le disais
sera coordonnée et commander depuis nos
éléments présents au niger
s'agissant de notre situation
sécuritaire
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
je dois dire elle s'est considérablement
améliorée sur l'ensemble de francs ou
notre armée a été engagée et elle a été
engagé sur au moins trois fronts le
front du combat que nous menons contre
boro haram dans la région du lac tchad
le flanc de notre combat que nous menons
à la frontière avec le burkina
ici nous avons au cours du mois de juin
passé mais n'est une opération conjointe
transfrontalière c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait inédit un peu nous de
l'armée du burkina faso et cette
coopération
a débouché sur des résultats comme nous
n'en avons jamais pu avoir une réduction
des forces militaires françaises au
sahel qui interroge écoutez l'analyse de
léon koungou politologue spécialiste en
relations internationales
je pense que c'est des engagements il
est il est très mal perçue il faut quand
même le sourire je pense que la france
appellerait ça fait une demande de dire
parce que aujourd'hui lorsqu'on met en
avant nous l'enfant se joint le geste à
elle agit de logis saint lys et la
mauritanie somalie donc vous qui la
façonnent bonne hygiène au tien c'est
une addition de faiblesse d une addition
une enfance dans nos dépanneurs
française laisse elle vit mais je pense
que les verts avaient lui après l'es6 et
de se substituer noah s'est substituée
aux efforts nationaux payants
donc c'est des substitutions était
problématique les problématiques dans la
mesure où elle a permis à des
mobilisations à dire d arguer nationale
certains ont même parlé d'une année aux
colonisations et lorsque le départ a été
annoncé
c'est la radio c'est un futur calme
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui il faut
néanmoins trouver une issue parce qu'on
se rend compte que le nombre
les talibans affirment contrôler 80% du
territoire arguant qu'une délégation
était reçue à moscou aujourd'hui parmi
les zones désormais contrôlé par les
insurgés deux importants postes
frontière avec l'iran et le turkménistan
depuis le mois de mai les talibans se
sont emparés de vastes zones rurales se
rapprochant de plusieurs grandes villes
et leurs offensives se poursuit alors
que joe biden vient de fixer la date
finale du retrait des troupes
américaines au 31 août
la russie appelle à la retenue la
correspondance devient goffman l'état
les bons garantissent que le territoire
de l'afghanistan ne sera plus jamais
utilisée par un pays tiers
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le chercheur
boudine de l'avare membre de l'équipe de
négociation de l'émirat islamique
d'afghanistan lors de sa visite à moscou
il a également promis que les talibans
ne saisiront pas des centres régionaux
par la force ils ne mèneront pas
d'activités militaires hostiles
je vous propose d'écouter la quatrième
manche nous garantissons que notre
territoire ne sera plus jamais utilisée
par un pays tiers nous voulons avertir
tout le monde que nous prendrons toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour que le
mouvement de l'état islamique
nos pères jamais sur le territoire
afghan et que notre pays ne soit pas
utilisée contre des pays voisins ou
contre des pays amis
nous affirmons que la production de
drogue est un problème mondial
nous assurons que nous prendrons des
mesures pour lutter contre la production
de drogue et voulons le garantir à la
communauté mondiale nous ne saisiront
pas des centres régionaux par la force
et nous ne mènerons pas d'activités
militaires hostiles
les propositions que nous avons
formulées indiquent qu'il n'y aura pas
d' attaque active sur les centres
administratifs des provinces tous les
prisonniers des deux côtés doivent être
libérés nous devons gagner la confiance
du peuple afghan pour construire la paix
ces propositions ont été transmises à la
partie américaine et aux autorités
officielles de kaboul par monsieur
khalil z
la délégation a également expliqué la
raison de son arrivée à moscou la russie
est un pays important dans la région de
l'afghanistan
il y a eu des développements récents et
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire de
parler avec eux de la situation récente
en afghanistan pour qu'ils nous
entendent pour discuter des diverses
inquiétudes
et aussi pour leur donner des
explications sur ce qui s'est passé dans
le pays
un arceau tougoudoum explanation à
baoding indycar
selon le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov la russie suit
de près ce qui se passe en afghanistan
où la situation tend à se détériorer
rapidement notamment dans le cadre du
retrait hâtif des troupes américaines
qui n'ont pas réussi à obtenir des
résultats tangibles en termes de
stabilisation de la situation en
afghanistan
après des décennies de présence dans ce
pays le soudan du sud fait son joueur
clé 10 ans de son indépendance une
décennie marquée par la violence la
corruption est désormais la crise
sanitaire
dans son discours ce matin le président
salva kiir a promis d'éviter un retour à
la guerre
robin qu elle la joie des premiers mois
d'indépendance a rapidement été remplacé
par les doutes et les crises
le soudan du sud est encore un pays
économiquement fragiles malgré des
ressources pétrolières importantes
le pays est exempte ruiné par cinq
années de guerre civile qui ont fait
près de 380 mille morts selon la banque
mondiale plus de 82% de la population
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté à jouba la
capitale les habitants ont perdu leur
optimisme j'avais l'espoir qu'un jour
nous serions une grande nation une
nation indépendante développé avec
beaucoup de ressources
mais ce que nous vivons actuellement
c'est une crise économique
tout est très cher et il faut réussir à
vivre à jouba imaginer qu'un kilo de
viande coûte aujourd'hui 10 dollars
américains
c'est vraiment richert pour nous qui
vivons avec moins d'un dollar par jour
ça va devenir encore pire l'alimentation
est en effet l'une des principales
préoccupations
malgré des terres fertiles l'agriculture
a été ravagée par les différents
conflits
les conditions climatiques de ces
dernières années ont également aggravé
une situation déjà critique
près de 7,2 millions de personnes sont
en situation d'insécurité alimentaire
une conjoncture très préoccupante pour
les dirigeants du programme alimentaire
mondial des nations unies qui opèrent
dans la région en tant qu'organisation
nous essayons de nous rire 5,3 millions
de personnes ici au soudan du sud
c'est donc l'une des plus grandes
opérations au monde et bien sûr lorsque
vous regardez ce que cela signifie pour
la population nous nourrissons un nombre
très important de sud soudanais et nous
ne le ferions pas si la situation
n'était pas aussi grave
avec une économie particulièrement
vulnérable aux chocs climatiques
pétroliers ou encore au conflit
interethnique
les chantiers sont encore nombreux pour
le gouvernement du soudan du sud un
futur d'autant plus incertain que les
élections initialement prévue en 2022
pour marquer la fin de la période de
transition ont été repoussées en 2023
partout dans le monde la faim progresse
elle s'est aggravée l'année dernière en
raison de la pandémie bien sûr mais à
cela s'ajoute le réchauffement
climatique et les situations de conflit
le dernier rapport de l ong oxfam saône
l'alertent serial bus et des cliniques
mobiles sillonnent le pays pour venir en
aide aux habitants en détresse pour
faire face à la famine
l'organisation médecins sans frontières
multiplie les dispositif médicalisé à
madagascar dans le sud de l'île la
sécheresse est celle que les habitants
sont contraints de manger des criquets
des feuilles de cactus ou encore de la
boue pour ne pas mourir de faim depuis
plus de 30 ans le changement climatique
fait des ravages sur les terres
malgaches qu'on allait vers de son
enfant et moi j'ai trouvé que ici
elle est en construction les plus
malades mais ça fait que deux visites
qu'on a fait ici et il ya encore
beaucoup d'enfants on veut rentrer mais
on n'a pas cette capacité aujourd'hui on
va revenir c'est sûr avec avec les
équipes plus grande
principaux facteurs aggravants qui se
rajoute à la main de six ans sont
principalement ballet chômage par
exemple qu'un les gens ils sont pas
ramassés le et sont plus de nourriture
et il y ait pas récolté bail
il n'y a pas d'emploi dont il ya pas des
revenus économiques l'echo vide et steph
aussi sa difficulté beaucoup les
opérations les mouvements les
acheminements de ressources et l'eau est
là à l'impact sur la population l'a
lâché serait ce là la bière soit presque
oui de quoi la sécheresse et la pandémie
de kovy 19 qui a également aggravé la
situation
médecins sans frontières pointe du doigt
l'insécurité qui fait rage et pousse les
familles à quitter leur village
même constat au mozambique où des
centaines de milliers de personnes ont
été déplacées par le conflit dans le
nord du pays selon le programme
alimentaire mondial
les enfants sont les principales
victimes dans ce conflit selon une
enquête de l'unicef et du programme
alimentaire mondial
50% des enfants déplacés souffrent de
malnutrition chronique
sans soutien financier rapide l'aide
alimentaire dans cette zone pourrait
cesser d'exister il fou dingue
si nous ne recevons pas un soutien
financier immédiat
nous serons très probablement contraint
de réduire l'aide alimentaire ou de la
suspendre complètement car nous avons
besoin de 121 millions de dollars pour
venir en aide à une population de sept
cent trente mille personnes
de septembre à décembre conflit
conséquences économiques du coc vie 19
et changement climatique aggrave
terriblement la faim dans le monde
ce vendredi oxfam a publié un rapport
alarmant selon les ong
155 millions de personnes dans le monde
sont désormais en situation de crise
alimentaire sans action immédiate
ce sont onze personnes qui mourront de
faim toutes les minutes
d'ici la fin de l'année et les regards à
présent de bruno parmentier consultant
spécialisé dans les questions agricoles
et alimentaires auteur du blog nourrir
longer points comme il ya une fac
chronique il faut se rendre compte
ça ça paraît à peine croyable mais il ya
autant de gens qui enfin aujourd'hui
qu'en 1911 1956 à peu près
et 800 millions de personnes qui se
couchent le soir avec le mât levante en
disant j'ai pas assez mangé comment je
fais pour manger demain à l'intérieur de
ces 800 millions de personnes il ya les
gens qui sont vraiment en menaces de
mort immédiat c'est à dire tout proche
de la famine
le problème il est considérable et il
faut beaucoup de mobilisations et
quelque part le on va dire les pays
riches regarde ailleurs
c'est pas leur problème finalement les
pays riches qu'on ait faim en hausse au
soudan du sud en haïti où ahmad ezz gare
donc à cette espèce d'isolement qui fait
qu'on les laisse mourir de faim elle
varie en delta poursuit sa course aucun
continent on est épargné en afrique le
sénégal tombe d'y faire face mais
l'accès au vaccin est difficile la
population se montre parfois sceptique
alors les autorités tentent de
convaincre les plus réticents
reportage à dakar de notre envoyé
spécial il a famous des patients de plus
en plus jeunes sans co morbidité et qui
développent des formes sévères c'est le
profil de malades professeur ca c
j'ai bien joué dans son service 2
ambitieuse
on voit plus de cas graves chez des
sujets jeunes pour l'envoyer au début de
la pandémie les jeunes c'est relâche
beaucoup plus parce que se sentant plus
en sécurité
il ya des figures de la lutte contre
l'épidémie au sénégal l'infectiologue
qui a été le premier à expérimenter
l'hydroxyde chloroquine pour traiter les
malades du public 19 se dit prêt à faire
face si la situation devait empirer
on pousse dans le dos dans l'aube aux
problèmes c'est faux les malades pour
les étudiants pour le chef mais il
insiste sur un élément
la vaccination reste le nerf de la
guerre la coupe 19 leurs esclaves
sommes-nous vraiment libres non vous
retrouvé notre vie normale pour trouver
notre liberté
il faut plusieurs musées c'est vrai mais
l'une des mesures phare c'est la
vaccination
on ne peut même pas comparer les risques
liés à la vaccination les risques liés à
la maladie n'y a pas de comparaison
possible
prends l'exemple de thrombose dont on
parle il y à là étaient notés 425 mille
fois plus de cas de thrombose chez les
patients atteints du coup vite que chez
les patients qui ont reçu leur vaccin
un discours qui a encore du mal à passer
auprès de la population sénégalaise en
moins de cinq mois
quelques 167 1000 doses
tes administrés sur une population de
près de 17 millions d'habitants
méfiance scepticisme alimenté par des
questionnements légitimes ou les rumeurs
les plus folles comme en europe et les
risques potentiels liés aux vaccins ont
donné un coup d'arrêt de campagne de
vaccination au début de la vaccination
j'ai entendu que certaines personnes qui
se sont fait vacciner on fait des avc et
d'autres en sont décédées c'est à cause
de tout ce que j'ai entendu et aussi
parce que je n'ai aucune maladie
chronique que je pense que pour moi il
n'y a pas lieu de se précipiter pour se
faire vacciner
[Musique]
nous avons ce que l'état veut nous
imposer c'est trop difficile
enfermé la population alors qu'on a déjà
pas les moyens de s'acheter à boire et à
manger avec la crise qu'on a au sénégal
c'est trop difficile
si on nous rajoute encore d'autres
obligations ça va être trop dur une
population excédée par plusieurs mois de
restrictions mais qui commence
progressivement à changer d'avis comme
le note le personnel soignant dans ce
centre de santé dans le quartier de yoff
on a enregistré
beaucoup de cas de refus par rapport au
bassinet
tempête
on va pratiquement personne mais là on
direct il sans donner
non
et par rapport aux personnes qui sont
venues déjà on a noté mois de cas
d'effets secondaires dans sa pire acqua
sur une prise de conscience qui est sur
le point de provoquer un autre problème
disposer de suffisamment de stock pour
répondre à la demande
l'objectif du sénégal vacciner au moins
20% de sa population d'ici la fin de
l'année particulièrement inquiets face à
la progression du variant delta le
continent asiatique la souche en
provenance d'inde fait des ravages
notamment en corée du sud le nombre de
cas positifs au co vide est
exponentielle dans le pays pour contenir
la propagation du virus les autorités
ont annoncé de nouvelles restrictions
farah mais qui l'inquiétude monte à
séoul
depuis quelques jours les centres de
dépistage sont de nouveau pris d'assaut
et pour cause le nombre de cas positifs
au kobus 19 explose plus de 1300 cas ont
été recensés en 24 heures dont une
partie importante dans la capitale un
record pour le pays qui avait pourtant
commencé à assouplir ses restrictions
fin juin pour les autorités sud
coréennes
l'heure est au rétropédalage s'il vous
plaît veuillez vous abstenir de sortir
ou d'organiser des rassemblements à
plusieurs respecter les directives de
les infections où que vous soyez même si
vous ne présentait aucun symptôme
veuillez vous protégez vous et vos
proches en vous faisant tester
nous pouvons et devons surmonter cette
crise le gouvernement fera de son mieux
lundi le dispositif de restriction le
plus sévère entrera en vigueur à séoul
et dans plusieurs régions voisines pour
une durée de deux semaines dans un
premier temps le gouvernement a interdit
les rassemblements de plus de trois
personnes après 18 heures les
restaurants devront cesser leur activité
après 22h et les écoles bars lieux de
culte et discothèques seront fermés
quant aux familles de malades
hospitalisés il leur sera désormais
impossible de rendre visite à leurs
proches
ces nouvelles contraintes inquiète la
population qu'ils pensaient être
définitivement débarrassé de toutes
nouvelles poussées épidémiques
je suis très stressée en raison de la
récente montée des cas de kevin 19
je suis venu me faire dépister car je
crains que le virus ne se propage
sérieusement et ne redevienne
préoccupant je ne m'attendais pas à
cette épidémie massive parce que ça fait
déjà un moment que nous avons commencé
les vaccinations
je suis donc assez surprise par cette
poussée soudaine en corée du sud
la vaccination progresse à un rythme
réduit car le pays fait face à une
pénurie de doses la campagne pourrait
néanmoins connaître prochainement une
accélération dans le cadre d'un accord
conclu entre séoul et tel aviv
un avion israélien transportant 700
mille doses de vaccin anti qu'ovide a
atterri mercredi sur le sol sud coréen
flambées épidémiques également au
vietnam les autorités ont donc décidé de
reconfirmer hô chi minh-ville
confinement strict de deux semaines neuf
millions d'habitants sont concernés chez
plutôt divisée sur le sujet écoute et le
confinement pourrait limiter les sorties
des gens et empêcher la propagation du
virus dans la communauté
je pense donc que la décision des
autorités est juste
le gouvernement peut redonner un
confinement mais je pense que c'est trop
difficile
cela affecte fortement la vie des gens à
cause des restrictions de déplacement ce
qui entraîne des conséquences sur les
activités commerciales et la thaïlande
renforce elle aussi ces mesures
sanitaires face à un nouveau pic
épidémique
un couvre-feu va être instaurée dans la
capitale bangkok ainsi que dans neuf
provinces du pays
avec ce vendredi le pays qui a
enregistré et plus de 9000 nouveaux cas
et 72 décès et en france les autorités
s'attendent à ce que ce variant delta
devienne majoritaire dès ce week end
emmanuel macron s'adressera lui aux
français lundi soir
il pourrait annoncer de nouvelles
mesures pour éviter une quatrième vague
en débat la question de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants le conseil
scientifique qui guide le gouvernement
la préconisent un projet de loi pourrait
être adopté avant fin juillet le
ministre de la santé s'est à nouveau
exprimé à ce sujet
en aucun cas il ne s'agirait de
stigmatiser des soignants on les
applaudit il sauve des vies
ce n'est pas une stigmatisation ans
c'est une protection depuis qu'on parle
de cette question la couverture
vaccinale augmente chez les personnels d
pad mais il faut que ça aille plus vite
à ce stade aucune décision n'a été prise
et c'est dans ce contexte d'inquiétudes
face aux mutations dieu coronavirus que
pfizer by one tech s'apprête à demander
aux agences de santé américaine et
européenne l'autorisation pour une
troisième dose de vaccin l'alliance
américano allemande qui annonçait hier
des résultats encourageants d'essai pour
une 3e injection avec cet objectif
augmenter l'efficacité de son vaccin
anti cauvigny compris contre le variant
bêta apparus en afrique du sud elle dit
s'attendre à des résultats similaires
pour le variant delta des cours des
tests sont en cours
cette troisième doses pourraient être
administrés six mois après la deuxième
injection
nous avons dit et nous continuons à
croire qu'il est probable en se fondant
sur la totalité des données que nous
avons à l'heure actuelle qu'une
troisième dose pourrait être nécessaire
entre six et douze mois après la
vaccination
un gouffre à présent du g20 finances
s'il s'est ouvert ce vendredi les
ministres concernés des 20 pays les plus
riches du monde sont réunis à venise en
italie au centre des débats la réforme
de la taxation des multinationales la
réforme qui ambitionne de mettre fin aux
paradis fiscaux
en instaurant un impôt mondial à d'au
moins 15% sur les bénéfices 131 pays acp
ont donné leur feu vert et bruno le
maire s'est dit confiant aujourd'hui si
on les écoute ça nous était un objectif
de refondation
au lendemain de la grande crise
économique et sanitaire que nous avons
connue d'abord aux fondations du système
de taxation internationale c'est le
premier objectif de ce g20 fonder un
nouveau système de taxation
internationale avec une taxe sur les
géants du numérique
c'est une question de justice 1 et une
taxation minimum à l'impôt ces sociétés
et cette taxation minimum à l'impôt des
sociétés
elle doit être ambitieuse elle doit
mettre fin à la course au moins disant
fiscal qui est une impasse totale depuis
des années en matière de fiscalité
internationale et elle doit être d'un
montant d'au moins 15% et la france va
se battre pour que le taux de cette
taxation minimale soit de plus de 15% je
le redis il faut être ambitieux pour que
ce soit juste et efficace
une taxe est pourtant loin de celle
annoncée est souhaitée il y a plusieurs
années
écoutez la réaction de dany langue
économiste membre des économistes
atterrés
il était sur notre antenne tout à
l'heure il faut pas surtout pas laisser
dire que c'est sous l'impulsion de la
france qu'on a ce type d'accord c'est
surtout sous l'impulsion des états unis
ne se bidonne qu'il faut le rappeler
voulait un ton minimum de 21 % ce qui
n'est quand même pas énorme
alors que
au début des années 80 les taudis y est
on est plutôt autour de 50 % donc là on
est 15 % si certains progrès au vu de ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières années
mais on est quand même très très loin
des niveaux qui questionne au début des
années 80 et des niveau qui serait
souhaitable pour avoir une fiscalité
juste entre la fiscalité sur le capital
et la fiscalité son travail et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain journal dans une
trentaine de minutes sera 21h nous
reviendrons sur le sommet du g5 celle
avec nos 200 invités pour en débattre
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise et fiable mais
comment peuvent-ils mentir comme des
arracheurs de dents ce point
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative on
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie
taxi en france l'activité a repris sdap
elmander paris ou pas les chauffeurs de
taxi affiliés à notre plateforme ont à
peu près le même nombre de courses par
jour cela l'avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé yaqub ya 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivée la
concurrence des vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé 20000 à 45
mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
je suis habitué à vivre dans la toundra
à la liberté et aux rênes
[Musique]
quand j'étais à l'école primaire en ce1
deux amis et moi même nous sommes enfuis
du pensionnat on est allé dans la
toundra
[Musique]
dans la toundra il n'y a que des
moustiques je ne comprends pas comment
les gens peuvent-ils vivre
comment pourrais-je envoyé mon enfant à
l'internât je n'en dormirais plus la
nuit
donc quand ils font face à irréel ils
n'ont aucune idée comment se débrouiller
il quitte l'école sans expérience
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qu'on va rendre obligatoire au
non vaccinés contre la bêtise
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du problème de la prédation sur
nos entreprises françaises bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ces caches bercy en a
identifié un peu plus de 500 depuis un
an et demi les alertes concernant les
menaces de prédation sur des entreprises
françaises se multiplient alors quelles
sont concrètement les entreprises
menacées comment contrer ses prédations
étrangères on va en parler dans cette
émission et pour cela nous recevrons en
deuxième partie frédéric pire uci ancien
cadre dirigeant d'alstom aujourd'hui à
la tête elle dit car ayant une société
de conseil le 6 et le service de
l'information à stratégique et de la
sécurité économique a été créé en 2016
il est rattaché à bercy et le gardent un
oeil sur les entreprises stratégiques
françaises et les menaces de prédation
qu'elles peuvent subir c'est son patron
qui a récemment agité les chiffons
rouges voyait pourquoi avec le tiroir
cage d'antoine basse
[Musique]
c'est une alerte ou danser il ya
quelques semaines par bercy les
entreprises françaises stratégiques
pourraient être menacés d'une prédation
en provenance de l'étranger
le chef du service de l'information
stratégique et de la sécurité économique
à bercy geoffrey célestin urbain l'a
affirmé il ya quelques semaines alors
que la france et le monde entier sont
plongés dans l'une des plus fortes
crises économiques de l'histoire
certains pays grandes puissances
économiques pouvant parfois même être
des alliés se sont élevées plus vite que
la france du coc vide ce qui les place
dans une position avantageuse pour aller
racheter des fleurons stratégiques chez
nous le service de l'information
stratégique et de la sécurité économique
déclare son niveau de vigilance
je cite très très élevé et il y a des
exemples récents concret en début
d'année bruno le maire avait dû mettre
son veto face à une menace de rachat de
carrefour par l'entreprise québécoise
couche tard autre exemple le
gouvernement s'était opposé au rachat de
photos nice une pme bordelaise
spécialisée dans les instruments de
vision nocturne par l'américain télé
d'ein bref bercy veille au grain pour
éviter toute perte qui met